[Music]
we are here at e3 2018 myself and Aaron
would play some battlefield 5 V whatever
you want to call it V for for victory V
for very thoughtful impressions as a
stretch so do you think the game it was
interesting so we've heard a lot about
battlefield 5 coming into this they've
released a lot of the details through
like us and youtubers there their press
conference made people a little worried
a little bit because yeah a bit too
bombastic but we finally got our hands
on the map we played a map called Narvik
which was in Norway it was a small small
infantry close-quarters map which to be
honest didn't really show off
battlefield strengths quite the way that
I would like so I think a lot of our oh
we have to talk about today is we have
to see a lot more of this game before we
could really form a strong opinion but
there was a lot of really good stuff to
talk about in this map did you like what
class did you primarily play as I mostly
played as the supports I wanted to try
out the the new fortification system and
that's some really cool moments there's
eye for brows using the Bren gun which
you could use kind of mobily and then I
upgraded to a medium machine gun the
mg42 which had to have a bipod it
actually to actually use properly so
that kind of played into the whole build
a fortification hunker down sort of
stuff there was moments where I like the
first time pushed towards an objective
throwing down sandbags put machine-gun
nests down and that felt like it was it
felt really satisfying because suddenly
I was taking all this fire and now I'm
safe I feel like I can defend this
objective but it's it's an odd once like
you were saying it's its battlefield
right to really have a strong opinion on
battlefield you need more than 20
minutes you need to be playing with with
your squad mates then have the ability
to communicate and in the demo didn't
really give me that which is a shame
because I was super excited to get my
hands on it yeah you need a large map to
really try it obviously another
battlefield shines so let's talk a
little bit more about the classes I
primarily leaned into the assault class
which was interests
because the assault class this time
around I thought they had most of the
goodies they had the anti-tank launchers
they had the dynamite they had the
assault rifles and we were having the
interesting conversation earlier where I
I I was killing it as assault and then I
pulled out my toolkit and I was like
yeah I'm gonna give this a try and I ran
up to like one of the berms and I built
a pile of snow yeah and then I ran up to
another berm and I built a couple of
sandbags and I wasn't sure what the game
was getting out with is with this
fortification system but you played his
engineer yeah so that's that's where the
fortification stuff really shines I
think it's another way to to kind of
emphasize that teamwork dynamic because
you saw a guy isn't going to be be able
to do everything else and if your whole
team is assault and medic then you're
not going to have these strong points to
defend it it really did feel like it was
necessary to have some variety in the
classes in your squad but but you're
completely right the assault the the
people that I count encountered during
the demo it was like 40 percent assaults
like 30 percent Scouts and then just
like a mixture of medic and engineer
that there weren't that many medics
which I was which is a shame because
battlefields in the previous have
emphasized medics and in battlefield 5
it's even more important to have medics
because you don't revive to fool you you
can only be revived by squad mates with
the buddy revive it's it's much it's
much more difficult to stay alive that's
it's much more intense it's really
important to get those resurrections off
and get those heals but there was no
medics on my team I think a lot of what
you're getting at 2 is a lot of the
systems right now are built towards
pushing people together in their squads
so things like ammo scarcity being able
to revive your buddies and squads but
not back to full health unless you're a
medic fortification system the roles
themselves seem a lot more specialized
but in an in casual play which is I
guess you could say we simulated in this
environment absolutely yeah we were with
strangers when we didn't have the
ability to communicate but that's gonna
be a problem like I actually found it
very difficult to tell who was in your
squad and it's weird because I think a
lot of what people were complaining
about with the
original reveal was that there wasn't
like immersion breaking stuff they
didn't they wanted a more immersive sim
but realistically I almost felt like
this needed a left4dead style outline of
at all times of who was in my squad
right because it was really easy to get
separated from your squad and then not
be able to tell where they were and
because these mechanics are so essential
in you being with your squad it made
everything a lot rougher like if you run
off on your own you are weaker you do
run out of ammo you can only build us a
bank of snow instead of a full-on
machine-gun nest but I really I do
really like that aspects it's it's I
feel so conflicted because the
individual gameplay elements like I
really like the ammo is scarce
I really like the medics Mario important
I really like that team players more
important and that the whole
fortification system all of them
separately I really like these new
gameplay elements but it's tricky
because the the demo that we had just
didn't let them shine enough and I think
I think now like I need to keep an open
mind or a battlefield because I did like
I said I didn't love them but I need to
spend much more time with the game I
need to experience like the proper
Battlefield Maps they're a wide-open and
really let that get battlefield gameplay
shine rather than the two couple of the
two days that we had that we felt very
close quarters and very assault class
centric it didn't it didn't give there's
so much that battlefield has but it
needs to breathe yeah and this felt very
claustrophobic and very confined and
it's it's going to be interesting and I
still am like super excited but yeah
they've done it twice now they're the
reveal didn't reveal everything that
they wanted it to reveal and now they're
demo isn't letting them show off
everything they want the demo to so it
feels like they're kind of handicapping
their own game is probably shame because
I really did enjoy it
there were some really cool moments I
mean that like battlefields about that
sort of emerging gameplay where you know
it's always gonna be silliness you never
quite know what your teammates gonna be
doing and there's a lot of them but
grant operations did have some cool
moments so the initial part of the game
starts with you actually physically
jumping out of an airplane and I did
have a really cool moment where I jumped
out of the airplane onto a like over a
flat gun that was trying to shoot down
the plane I was deploying from and I
actually parachuted and landed and then
just kind of hooked a grenade into the
nest and blew the guy up who is in there
so you have you do have those you can
see you can see glimpses of what they're
going yeah like those moments are there
how did you feel about grand operations
in general I really liked the idea of it
the fact that it that day one has a
knock-on effect on day two alternatively
when I was playing the defending side I
saw inventory jumping out of those
planes and I had like an mg42 and I was
like me and my squad were just shooting
into the sky trying to kill paratroopers
again that felt really cool into those
players
it was probably quite exciting to be
trying to drop and having these he's
bullets whizzed past it did feel like
there was like the defenders had an
easiest time of it but again battlefield
is a game that needs to be learned and
people need to invest time in it it's
not really fair to assume that all the
attackers
they're just trying out this game you
know like demo are going to be doing
like they're gonna PTF oh they won't
experience stuff which is completely
fair but it does mean that squads were
moving together and attacking these
objectives it's it's so weird I've again
I feel so conflicted because I really do
dig this game but I need to see it in a
way that lets Battlefield be battlefield
and that just wasn't it but at the same
time like you me both massive
battlefield fans so you can guarantee
that as soon as we get to see it again
one of us is going to be all over that
so if you want to see more about
Battlefield either one of us is gonna be
able to fill you in
so make sure you subscribe to GameSpot
for the battlefield 5 stuff and for
everything else
III 2018 and we'll see you next time
[Music]